la vaccination a pris plus de temps à
démarrer à cause de la logistique
nécessaire aux vaccins arn messagers
notamment le respect de la chaîne du
froid les premières doses sont donc
arrivés plus tard dans les territoires
d'outre-mer pour mayotte par exemple il
faut attendre le 28 janvier soit
pratiquement un mois après le démarrage
de la campagne de vaccination en
métropole le 26 décembre
nous n'avons pas eu la même offre
vaccinale qu'en métropole c'est simple
certains vaccins ne sont pas disponibles
ici moi par exemple c'est le médecin du
sénat qui m'a vacciné parce qu'un vaccin
sans arrêt n'était pas disponible en
guadeloupe je réalise ma chance mais
tout le monde n'a pas accès aux médecins
du sénat le gouvernement a misé en
priorité sur la vaccination des
personnes âgées une stratégie inadaptée
dans certains territoires d'outre-mer où
la population est en moyenne plus jeunes
qu'en métropole mais davantage atteint
deux facteurs de comorbidité comme le
diabète ou l'obésité
les élus ont rapidement réclamé un
élargissement de la cible vaccinale mais
le gouvernement a tardé à autoriser cet
aménagement
s'ajoute à cela la difficulté d'accès
aux soins pour une partie de la
population
concentrée les doses dans les grands
centres de vaccination limite la
distribution du vaccin dans les
territoires plus isolé les autorités se
heurtent également un important
mouvement de défiance sur les questions
de santé publique
l affaire du chlordécone a renforcé la
méfiance vis-à-vis des politiques du
gouvernement et notamment martinique
chlordécone pesticide classés par l' oms
comme concerts et gêne probable est
diffusée dans certains départements
d'outre-mer jusqu'au milieu des années
le côté d'un facteur de la vaccination
en martinique tiennent de plusieurs
choses je pense que d'abord ça tient de
l'histoire de la martinique de ses
relations avec la france je pense que
est passée par là aussi tout ce qui est
chlordécone touski vih tout ce qui est
manque de confiance entre les politiques
en martinique mais aussi entre l'état et
les martin auteur dont toutes ces choses
là tout le monde qui plus est les
informations qui sont de part et d'autre
sur les réseaux sociaux et ailleurs met
en place en situation de doute
généralisé qui ne fait que renforcer
cette soupe et 7 non volonté d'être
probablement vacciner aux antilles la
population nourrit un attachement
particulier à la médecine traditionnelle
avant la pandémie le scepticisme
vis-à-vis des vaccins étaient déjà plus
prononcée qu'en france métropolitaine
l'herbe à pic a été présentée comme un
moyen de lutte contre le virus son
efficacité n'a pas été démontrée
scientifiquement mais elle symbolise
l'attachement d'une partie des habitants
à la médecine traditionnelle